like it or not the holidays will
inevitably end and life will crash back
into its normal routines with all its
jobs and stress and winter chores winter
ice so relax a little and enjoy some of
Netflix's newest releases January sees
the addition of some incredible new
programming to ring in the new year
here's what's in store for January 2018
starting with the Netflix originals bla
say
season 1 if you like the French show
lair of none you're bound to fall in
love with Netflix's newest French
offering plus a also known as the frozen
dead in English plus a is set high on an
isolated mountain range where a police
officer stumbles across a small-town
mystery that's been kept in the dark for
years look for it January 1st lovesick
season 3 considering that this show's
original release title was scrotal
recall you can get a pretty clear idea
of what kind of humour to expect
the story starts when Dylan finds out he
has an STD and decides to visit every
girl he's been with to warn them about
it happy been the show originally aired
on the UK's Channel four in 2014 and
Netflix began airing it as an original
with the second season
check out season 3 of lovesick when it
drops January 1st before I wake directed
by Mike Flanagan before I wake is about
a couple's newly adopted son who has the
uncontrolled ability to manifest his
dreams in the real world haunted by
real-life nightmares
the couple played by Kate Bosworth and
Tom Jane have to figure out why their
little orphan boy is inadvertently
unleashing his night terrors on the
world before I wake was filmed in 2013
but the release date was continually
pushed back until the movie was dropped
from relativities release schedule
altogether netflix acquired the film's
international rights in 2017 and
proceeded to release the film everywhere
except in the United States but the wait
is finally over before I wake will hit
us Netflix on January 5th five years
after it was made
comedians in cars getting coffee Jerry
Seinfeld's Emmy award-winning web series
has been running since 2012 and it's
making the move to Netflix as part of
Seinfeld's massive jillion dollar deal
with the streaming service rebranded as
a Netflix original the series
about well exactly what it says on Fox
comedians hang out in a car getting
coffee then they talk about things and
it's hilarious if somehow you've missed
this show over the years you'll be able
to catch up on every episode on January
5th along with 24 brand-new episodes
available only on Netflix devil man
crybaby season 1 an adaptation of one of
the most violent gratuitous mangas of
the 70s devil man crybaby is easily one
of the most hotly anticipated anime
releases of the new year the story
centers on a boy who merges with a demon
to become devil man in hopes of stopping
Hell from taking over the earth in their
review of the first three episodes anime
now basically described the show as a
mature version of the Looney Tunes
buckle in for the ride on January 5th
rotten this six-part documentary series
dives into the global food industry to
take a look at modern farming practices
and the impact they're having on the
world
rotten promises to dig into corruption
in the agricultural business food
additives and all the other hot-button
food issues whether it hits or misses
there's one thing you can count on a ton
of terrible rotten tomatoes puns once
the review start rolling in check it out
for yourself on January 5th Alejandra
Rihanna speciale distend up the first
new comedy special to hit Netflix in the
new year is Alejandro Ryan yo especi
Alba stand-up in which we will see the
Colombian comedian taking the stage to
deliver his unique brand of rapid-fire
jokes take a look on January 6th
disjointed Bart to the first season of
Kathy Bates stoner comedy disjointed
wasn't exactly a smoking success at
least where the critics were concerned
the story centers on Ruth Feldman a Los
Angeles dispensary owner with a team of
vaguely competent bud tenders one of
whom is her own son the first 10
episodes were released August 25th and
Netflix is set to roll out the rest of
the season on January 12 2018 somebody
feed Phil now this isn't a resurgence of
Viva La Bam somebody feed Phil is a
traveling cooking show following Phil
Rosenthal the creator of Everybody Loves
Raymond and self-proclaimed foodie as he
travels around the world tasting the
best cuisine the planet has to offer
Rosenthal is no stranger to culinary
travels he previously starred in the
Cemil
series I'll have what Phil's having
which is also available on Netflix
checkout somebody be Phil on January
12th the Polka king based on the
real-life story of yon LaVon a polka
personality who concocted a Ponzi scheme
that stole somewhere in the neighborhood
of ten million dollars the Polka King is
a new Netflix original film starring
Jack Black the feature film draws from
the 2009 documentary the man who would
be polka king which is also arriving on
Netflix on January 12th you can't stop
the polka Tom Segura disgraceful veteran
stand-up comic and podcaster Tom Segura
is arriving with an all-new special on
January 12th making it his third
full-length special on Netflix if it's
anything like Segura's other stand-up
disgraceful will be full of his sharp
wit low-key delivery and completely
irreverent topics find out On January
12th Katt Williams great America comic
legend Katt Williams has been making
audiences laugh since well before he
became a household name in 1999 in 2018
he's still going strong his newest
special great America arrives on January
16th tiempos de gata season 1
translating two times of war Chiapas de
gata is an upcoming scripted Spanish
series set during the Spain Morocco war
of 1921 the show follows the nurses and
doctors of a hospital tasked with
treating wounded soldiers so get ready
for lots of historical trauma you can
start watching on January 18th Grace and
Frankie season for over three seasons
viewers have been delighted by the
escapades of Grace and Frankie which
follows two women who find out that
their husbands have been having an
affair for the past 20 years
with each other Shawn and I are in love
excuse me you're gay we want to get
married because we can do that I know I
hosted that fundraiser Lily Tomlin and
Jane Fonda star is the leading ladies
with Sam Waterson and Martin Sheen is
their ex-husbands cue up season 4 On
January 19th the open house not to be
confused with the 2010 bum open house or
the 1987 cult horror b-movie of the same
name the open house is a 2018 horror
film about a mother and son who moved
into a new house only to
their lives threatened by mysterious
forces the open house seized yet another
Netflix collaboration with actor Dylan
Manette who also starred in 13 reasons
why the open house well opens on January
19th Todd glass act happy Todd glass
entered the national consciousness with
his appearances on NBC's reality show
Last Comic Standing and he since gone on
to make a name for himself as one of the
funniest comedians in the business look
for his new special act happy on January
23rd ricardo kobato hi ntsc Netflix has
been loading up on foreign acquisitions
lately in 2018 we'll see a wave of new
multilingual comedians like Ricardo
kobato a Colombian native who was
featured on Comedy Central's stand-up
Without Borders now he's hitting Netflix
with int AC check it out On January 24th
a futile and stupid gesture National
Lampoon gave us such comedy gems as
Animal House and vacation along with
more questionable gems like everything
else they've made get ready for Van
Wilder freshman year but there's no
doubt the magazine and its films have
made a lasting mark on popular culture
that's the angle of a futile and stupid
gesture a film about the early days of
the national sensation and its eventual
downfall
check it out on January 26th Dirty Money
along with their food expose rotten
Netflix is also releasing a documentary
investigation into the world's largest
corporations created by Alex Gibney who
won an Oscar for his documentary taxi to
the dark side dirty money will be an
episodic series with multiple
documentarians taking the helm for
different episodes take a look on
January 26th one-day-at-a-time
season 2 loosely based on the series of
the same name that first aired in 1975
one-day-at-a-time
follows a family with three generations
living under the same roof as they try
to make their lives work following
summit reviews for the first season
released in 2017 Netflix announced plans
to release a second season in 2018 all
13 new episodes drop on January 26th
Babylon Berlin seasons 1 & 2 set in the
1920s this German language drama follows
a police commissioner whose
transferred to Berlin to investigate the
Russian mafia touted as the most
expensive German show ever produced
Babylon Berlin enjoyed strong ratings in
Germany and Netflix secured the us
distribution rights well before the
first episode aired both seasons will
drop on Netflix on January 30th that
covers all the Netflix originals now
let's take a look at everything else
arriving on Netflix in January 2018 new
movies Oscar season arrives early on
Netflix with multiple Award winners and
nominees slated to land on the service
in January 2018 on the first of the
month look out for dramas such as The
Godfather trilogy The Shawshank
Redemption Midnight in Paris and
training day King Kong on the action
front the first of the year also sees
the addition of most of the Batman films
starting with 1989 s Batman all the way
to 2005 s Batman Begins yep even Batman
and Robin if I must suffer humanity will
suffer with me plus go ahead and let
that holiday spirit linger a little
longer with the second best Christmas
movie written by Shane Black lethal
weapon and all its sequels land on
January 1st in the same spirit Christmas
may be over but there's never a bad time
of year to experience the ups and downs
of Richard curtis's modern classic Love
Actually that arrives on Netflix on
January 1st along with other comedies
like wedding crashers Caddyshack and the
bring it on pentalogy yeah they made
five of those if you're making it a
resolution to watch more documentaries
in 2018 Netflix has you covered there
too the first of the month sees the
addition of 2017 documentaries like
alphago madman the Steve Madden story
and Martin Luther the idea that changed
the world
Netflix's kids line up is geared toward
the whole family this January
New Year's Day heralds the addition of
the 1971 classic Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory
along with 2007 Stardust based on the
Neil Gaiman novel of the same name and
on the 31st Disney Pixar's Cars 3 will
be available for streaming finally the
weather won't be the only thing that's
giving you chills this January Netflix
is adding a handful of thrillers to
their services 2018 rolls through the
door including 30 days of night The
Exorcism of Emily Rose and Peter
Jackson's slow-burning The Lovely Bones
on the first of the month as January
continues you can look forward to the
conjuring on the 8th and the 2017 sharp
vest 47 meters down on the 10th new
television while most of Netflix's new
television offerings in January will be
Netflix originals you'll still be able
to find new seasons of some shows
highlights include season 3 of East
Siders on the first all five seasons of
episodes On January 6 and season 2 of
colony on the 12th also keep an eye out
for the 2018 Olympic Winter Games
preview on January 15th and season 4 of
Friday night tykes on the 17th finally
January 28th heralds the arrival of the
Ministry of Time a spanish-language
time-travel adventure series no matter
what you're in the mood to watch this
January you're bound to find something
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]